على ارضيه ما تراها مصر صلبه تعود
العلاقات مع تركيا بعد 11 عاما من
الانقطاع والقطيعه حتى اقدموا وزير
الخارجيه التركيه في القاهره لتوضع خطوط
عريضه لعوده ثنائيه تستهل برفع التمثيل
الدبلوماسي بين البلدين والاتفاق على
تسميه سفراء جدد خلال العام الحالي مصادر
العربيه اكدت ان قمه مصريه تركيه ستجمع في
النصف الثاني من العام بين الرئيسين عبد
الفتاح السيسي ورجب طيب اردوغان ممن جدول
زمني
[موسيقى]
في خط زمنيا متسارع لرد من هو او هكذا عقد
العزم على عوده العلاقات المصريه التركيه
دشنت المصافحه الشهيره للرئيسين السيسي
واردغان في نوفمبر الماضي بدايه مرحله
جديده على هامشي افتتاح مونديال قطر 45
دقيقه من الحديث بحسب اردوغان اذنت لما
سياتي بعدها السابع والعشرون من فبراير
دبلوماسيه الزلزال غير المتوقع عجلت خطوات
القاهره نحو انقره اقتضت زياره وزير
الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري لتسليم شحنه
مساعدات اغاثيه مصريه لتركيا وسبقها اتصال
تضامن رئاسيا مصري وزير الخارجيه التركيه
اليوم يبدا ما اقرته بلاده في الثامن
والعشرين من نوفمبر على لسانه باعاده
علاقات مصر وتركيا الدبلوماسيه بالكامل في
الاشهر المقبله تشوش شغله في القاهره
اليوم ومن القاهره يقول
نشكر الحكومه المصريه على المساعدات التي
قدمتها في هذه الفتره ما يعبر عن التضامن
بين البلدين فان العلاقه بين تركيا ومصر
هي علاقه تاريخيه وثقافه مشتركه لذلك نود
ان نقوي هذه العلاقه بيننا الامر الذي
يحتاج الى مساعده من الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي والرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ونحن نعمل
على تسهيل عقد لقاء بينهما